this is how I want Rick to die this is
Alan do you want to hear it I was gonna
say everybody its Charlie you've
probably seen the news by now everybody
is freaking out because Andrew Lincoln
has formally announced that he's going
to be leaving The Walking Dead after
season nine
they didn't say they're gonna be killing
him off or anything like that obviously
I had that funny clip about him saying
how he wants Rick to die I'll play the
rest of that later in the video here
because it's actually pretty funny but
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos obviously this is a really huge
deal so people are just trying to make
sense of it like what's gonna happen to
the Walking Dead without Rick Grimes
what most of the news outlets are
reporting or is that they've offered
Norman Reedus a substantial pay upgrade
to take over Andrew Lincoln's lead role
in the show so Darrell's already a main
character but he's been kind of
background lately he would effectively
become the new focal point of the show
so however you feel about Darrel it
sounds like season 10 of The Walking
Dead will be the dare all season if he
felt like there hasn't been a season
that's focused on him before he said
some really big arcs but I think we're
all just wondering how long can they go
without their biggest characters spoiler
warning for what's happened on The
Walking Dead recently if you jumped off
the show and you're planning on catching
up later there will be spoilers in here
for the most recent season so this past
season the big death was Carl they
killed him off which is a huge deal
because in the comics he's arguably the
future of the story of the survivors
group he's meant to take over when Rick
Grimes eventually dies so we don't need
to get into comic book spoilers but
Robert Kirkman has said in the past that
he plans to end the Walking Dead comic
book when Rick Grimes eventually dies
like the series is meant to follow his
life over his 300 issue plus run so it's
not like it's gonna go for forever you
could tell that AMC makes so much money
on The Walking Dead main show that they
would love to keep it on the air for
forever if they could so there's been a
couple recent shows on other big
networks that have tried to keep
themselves alive after their original
main cast of left it hasn't gone well
like once upon a time is a good example
where like all the main actors left the
show they tried to do another see
with some of the B characters and it
completely fell flat so they canceled
the show after that extra season which
is why you know I definitely think that
they're gonna go for season 10 because
they'll go through season 9 you'll get
Rick Grimes we'll find out what ends up
happening to him Andrew Lincoln leaves
the show you still have Michonne you
still have Jesus you still have some of
the hilltop people there are pretty big
characters that are around Maggie for
instance is another example of a
character that's probably gonna leave
soon though lauren cohan is supposed to
only be coming back for a handful of
episodes during season 9 like 6 maybe a
little bit more than that assuming that
there's 16 episodes total that's not a
lot of screen time compared to what you
would see from her in a normal season
but what they'll probably do is it'll
just load up on her scenes when she does
come into episodes
there's still a couple really big arts
that they haven't done yet that I expect
them to do because they're so popular
you have the whispers whisper war you
have the Commonwealth as a big group of
people that they could introduce which
they're doing right now in the comics
even though the comics are way further
ahead in the timeline than what's going
on in the show right now just to put the
story and the characters into context
there are a couple big turns that happen
down the road The Walking Dead
like I said intended to be like a 300
plus issue comic book and Robert
Kirkman's eyes there were only add about
issue 180 so they're a long ways away
from the inevitable end of the comic
book series so think about all the years
that Rick Grimes has left to live in the
comics kill him off on the TV show and
what's that gonna do to ratings because
I mean Daryl is a hugely popular
character Maggie's pretty popular but
she's not daryl popular and she might
not even come back for season 10 because
lauren cohan signed to another TV show
so it's kind of like a jumping back and
forth situation for Walking Dead Season
9 already it's a bit of a scheduling
problem for her if you didn't see the
season 8 finale video that it did I
talked a little bit about the behind the
scenes changes structurally in the way
they managed this show Scott Gimple
isn't gonna be the showrunner anymore
he's transitioning to more of an
oversight role for more spin-off shows
that they're gonna try and develop so
like to have fear of The Walking Dead
they said that there's gonna be more
Walking Dead spin-offs in the future
that they're gonna try to launch he'll
have something to do with that Morgan
has already gone on to fear The Walking
Dead he'll probably stay there for a
while especially if the main show winds
down they might also try and sink the
storylines
so that more of the main cast goes to
fear the walking dead after season 10 if
it really does look like that's gonna be
one of the final seasons but I mean with
the way the ratings are going even
though they're bleeding viewers they are
still doing way bigger numbers than your
average TV show so even with the decline
in viewership they could still keep
going for a couple more years with these
B characters and people like Daryl
leading the show tonight career uh would
probably stick around I would be willing
to bet - she becomes the main leader
even if Daryl becomes the series lead
because Daryl you know very interesting
character but he's not much of a leader
so when you really dig into it like if
they give him a big pay bump and they
pay him as much as they used to pay
Andrew Lincoln that just means that he's
gonna have more scenes more storylines
it's not like he's gonna start ordering
people around to start doing everything
because Michonne is probably one of the
few people next to Carol or even Ezekiel
he just takes over leadership of the
survivors - but I still think they want
to have the different encampments but
they are kind of converging on each
other so we might get back to a
situation in the first couple of seasons
like we had where everybody was all
together at the same time instead of
having like four separate groups that
you have to go to in different episodes
so post all your reactions in the
comments about Andrew Lincoln leaving
and what you think is gonna happen to
the show after he does like how many
more seasons can they get out of this
but here's the rest of that funny video
with him talking about how he wants Rick
Grimes to die and this was recorded
before they killed off Carl on the TV
show so he references him a couple times
during this we're going through a desert
somewhere and I jump off the bus I'm
telling it I'm saying it he like he
likes it I told it I said it in Madrid
and he went don't tell anybody because
it's good so I just in a very heroic
acts Rick jumps off Karl's
he's still alive and what about Carl him
and maybe that's the last thing I say
[Applause]
I jump I jump I jump off I jump off and
I'm like come flute kicking all that you
know earn my action figure right
hopefully do I get bit
doesn't matter keep going Carl hey
they've gone to desert high shop
beautiful high shop anyway
deal with that stuff you know I get that
and I'm dying on my own on my own just
waiting to die and it go and then I'm
waiting i patch up and then a day pass
[Laughter]
anyway I don't final shot is holy
maybe I'm the cure
so obviously what's gonna happen later
this summer is they'll have a comic-con
trailer for season 9 hopefully at that
panel they'll address what they're gonna
do with the show after season 10 if they
start losing more of their main cast but
I'll have new Marvel to post tomorrow
leave all your requests in the comments
below
but click here for brand new Avengers 4
and click here for all my Walking Dead
videos thank you so much watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight